j'avais comment ça fait plaisir d'être
avec toi chez moi ça me fait plaisir
d'être avec moi
je peux pas savoir comment je suis
heureux que tu as accepté de présenter
le Jamel Comedy Club non tu m'as pas dit
je prenne par contre toi tu m'as dit au
présent tu m'as pas dit je présente
non si
c'est là j'ai dit tu représentes tout
seul
que présenter Jamel c'est deux coups
c'est toujours deux coéquipiers copilote
colocataire causes c'est toi et moi
aussi de quoi
que ces deux connard c'est combien qu'on
a il y a combien de personnes donc on a
rien
qu'est-ce qu'il y a c'est quoi ton
problème la vérité non je suis content
Alban Alban regarde vous êtes chaud ou
pas
[Applaudissements]
il y a Janelle qui représente tout seul
tu me réponds jamais debout s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]